alors je vous dis on va apprendre un
sujet qui touche environ 90% des gamer
d'entre nous à savoir geek et quand il
ya du soleil ou temps où tu as où elles
sont alors déjà je trouve ça un peu
triste kong etc alors celle du soleil
dehors bon y'en a quand même qui font
l'effort de sortir faire des batailles
de boules c'est vrai bon quand il sent
quand tu veux pas le ballon c'est un
problème s'incline et à côté de sa
course semble plutôt à ça en fait je
plante en b les mecs qui disent oh là il
dit hélas la trépanation c'est un peu
comme une odeur contes en hiver et tout
ça passe encore c'est notre show tout ça
moi par contre en été c'est quand même
autre chose quoi le moyen de quitter au
soleil mes amis ne m'appelle plus
vampires je suis assez content 4 oh là
là qu'on saura pas ce que je fais au
bout de deux minutes en plein soleil
doit tourner des explosifs désolé pour
cette a3 paris en ce temps de jauger sur
un père mario un mario super agent dans
lequel en fait ya des pièges partout et
en fait super beau faire le truc encore
encore et encore pour comprendre sur le
piège et y arriver j'ai fait niveau 1 on
va faire le nouve au niveau 2 alors
bon bah ouais sont autant d'enjeux l'a
tellement ces dernières tendances et en
europe
allez hop donc un double juste avant moi
qu'ils ont nié dac
la deuxième homme le truc c'est que je
vous disais ah bravo voiture nivard
promène deuxième tube up deuxième tube
instantané en plus de m
[Musique]
mais quelle bande de bâtards de fourbe
ok le pont le pont l'herbe le trouve
[Musique]
ok le pont le pont à l'autre ou le sol
tackler ma fille tu dis il faut faire là
j'ai pas confiance à un petit truc
grille je sens que nous apporter que des
emmerdes
on y va quand même pas que jamais faire
confiance à un inconnu c'est là que même
un vrai que le temps c'est fait
[Musique]
plab le truc le machin le premier tube
le deuxième tube on retourne mon retour
mon fond son sens au mot pas sauter au
site en [ __ ] j'ai cette pièce continue
alors obligé un trou des pics [ __ ] de
jute fallait s'en douter fallait s'en
douter pas en douter fallait s'en douter
fallait s'en douter
en fait sans doute et bah oui bah oui
enfin fallait pas oublier ces moments là
je peux jouer ou pas à la tension
attention attention tu vois pas qu'ils
avaient des [ __ ] pièces dans fight
forme de mer au québec
[Musique]
ouais
le vais te complais tête et est décédé
des voitures de merde j'avais eu un
petit cube qui est apparue la whey juste
la troupe explique non mais soutient la
informe quoi troisième cub s'est fait
lui lie à l'ex lillois
[Musique]
haha tu m'as pas eu vilain piquer les
flèches royal et vas-y mario ou pire
appel witschi course passe une courte
échelle
la blague de beauf coaching on laisse
qu'une pique quoi ces pays qu'ils
étaient ici même mais regardez-moi
centre tuant six et en musique
on fait qu' au top non complet no
comment est ce possible et des navets
salle st point nos missions 70 sarrapy
kenneth cochonnet ce truc ne me touchait
pas ça me touchait ma patte de ferme
je joue mais [ __ ] le vrai buzz que ça
me met en transe eux je te merde faut
s'énerver dans les jeux leur montrer que
tu es vénère folie
on est reparti c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave on y va
j'arrive au milieu donné un bon swing
ont mis le début d'un quart et là c'est
l'endroit où je suis bloqué saute
partout et je fonce si je me prends un
trou mais quoi ok ok ok
ok j'ai donné le truc j'ai deviné le
truc mais sa meilleur de moi-même daphné
petite boule rouge direct et pocket
boulez dans l'impulsion de crâne
mais qu'est ce qu'ils foutent elle astro
de aide à aller avance avance avant
avant avant hop
[Musique]
fête à prier a fallu brauman je t'aurais
prévenu qu'est ce qui m'arrive
quel sorcellerie utilises tu donnes tu
succombera sous les